♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is the first puppy
up tonight.
Named Gary Frick Jr.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And here's how it's gonna work.
I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And if you answer correctly,
you will receive
a golden retriever puppy.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-That's the way it works.
-If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
And whoever has the most puppies
at the end of the game
is the Pup Quiz champion.
Keanu, since you're our guest,
you'll answer the first question
and either win or lose
Mr. Gary Frick Jr.
-Okay.
-What is the only species
of reptile --
-I'm so terrible with this.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
He didn't even finish
the question.
-I know. I just know it's just
gonna be a disaster.
-No, come on.
-It's just -- go ahead.
-You're gonna get this one.
What is the only species
of reptile native to Ireland.
Is it, A, snake...
-Come on.
-...B, lizard, or, C, turtle?
Not sea turtle.
C, turtle.
-Native to Ireland.
Okay.
So all of those are kind of,
like, the thing and what's
gonna be the thing,
and then what's the thing that
you don't think it's gonna be,
so you're gonna say turtle.
-Right.
But then you're gonna
change your answer to...
-Uh, uh, lizard.
[ Laughter ]
-Lizard. Yes!
Lizard is correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You win Gary Frick Jr.
-Hey, buddy.
-Come on.
This is not fair.
First of all,
I'm not taking a puppy
away from John Wick.
[ Laughter ]
Just saying that right now.
-Okay.
This next question's for you,
Jimmy.
-Okay.
-Where you going?
-Which of the following species
is not the name
of a real animal?
Okay?
Which of the following
is not the name
of a real animal species?
Is it, A, sarcastic fringehead,
B, spiny lumpsucker,
or, C, shorty bobbit.
-The following is not the name
of a real animal species.
I think it's
sarcastic fringehead.
-Sarcastic fringehead.
Is that your final answer?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It is?
-No!
Answer was shorty bobbit.
Oh, shorty bobbit.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
Now Keanu wins the adorable
puppy, Mary Kennedy.
-Oh.
Do they know each other?
Do the puppies know each other?
Is this, like, a common litter?
-We have like
50 puppies backstage.
[ Laughter ]
-You got Gary and Mary.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh, my gosh! Do you hear that?
-No.
-That sound means it's time
for Double Puppardy.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Double Puppardy?
-Questions are now worth
two puppies.
[ Laughter ]
-Watch out.
-Keanu.
-What?
-A dik-dik...
[ Laughter ]
A dik-dik is what kind
of animal?
Is it, A, platypus --
A platypus.
B, is for bird, or C, antelope,
not cantaloupe.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. So, you do the one
that you think it's gonna be,
but then you pick the one that
you don't think it's gonna be,
and then you pick the one that
and then the dik-dik
is an antelope.
-That is correct!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you out of your mind?
-Keanu, you and Lisa McAdams
and Lisa Armstrong.
-Double Puppardy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Let's go, Fallon.
-Come here, boy.
That's it. Come here, boy.
That's a good boy.
-It's puppy love!
-You give that one back --
-That's my puppy, Fallon!
-I love it.
-All right, next question
goes to Jimmy.
Why do males dogs raise their
leg when is they urinate?
[ Laughter ]
Is it, A, to tell others
they are tall?
Is it, B, to tell other dogs
they are happy?
Or it is, C, to tell other dogs
they are DTF.
[ Laughter ]
Down to fetch.
-Maybe, uh, B?
-No, it's to tell other dogs
they are tall.
[ Sad tuba ]
So, Keanu, you get Roger Blaine
and Ted Mooney.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Can you help the dogs?
-Hi.
-Who's the puppy king?
-Come here.
There you go.
-I'm the puppy king!
-There we go.
He's got 'em.
All right.
[ Laughs ]
-Hey, buddy.
-Okay.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh, my gosh!
That sound means it's time
for Final Puppardy.
This is for all your opponent's
puppies and the game.
So pick up your iPads
if you can.
[ Laughter ]
How many dogs were used
to film the movie "Air Bud"?
All right.
You'll have 10 seconds
on the clock starting now.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-They left, they left.
They just left.
They left.
-Oh!
-They left, okay?
They're wandering --
[ Buzzer ]
It's chaos.
I'm gonna say 10.
-Keanu, what did you write down?
-Uh, 6, but if it's not 6,
then it's a 9.
[ Laughter ]
-The answer is 6!
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There we go.
My thanks to Keanu Reeves,
these adorable puppies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Uh, Higgins -- Higgins --
Higgins, can you --
Higgins, can you explain how --
[ Cheering continues ]
-Yes, I can, Jimmy!
-Yes.
Explain how the game works.
-Jimmy and Suga will be given
two things to eat
that look identical.
One tastes good...
and the other does not.
-Okay.
They must eat
what they are presented with
while trying to convince
the audience
that they like the taste.
Then the audience will vote
for who they think
ate the gross thing.
There'll be three rounds.
Okay?
-Three rounds. Okay.
-You ready?
-Yeah, I'm ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
For the first round,
we have two spoons.
One has salt and one has sugar.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, you will go first.
-Go first.
-You're --
You're my guest.
All right, so one is salt,
one is sugar.
-Jimmy, whenever you're ready.
-All right. And --
-That's your spoon.
♪♪
Mmmmm!
[ Laughter ]
Suga, it's your turn.
Eat whenever you are ready.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Okay. Audience?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Audience,
time to cast your votes.
[ Laughter ]
You all have your voting
clickers at your seat.
If you think Jimmy
ate the salt...
-I tried.
-...vote Jimmy.
If you think Suga ate the salt,
vote Suga.
Ready, guys?
Vote away.
I think it's pretty obvious
who had the salt,
but maybe some people
aren't convinced.
I tried to act like...
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-Yep.
All right. The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
-Oh, Jimmy.
The audience thinks Jimmy
is the imposter.
Jimmy, let's find out
who actually
ate the salt.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
-He ate the salt.
-I'm the imposter.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow.
-You thought he was acting?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he's just -- He's --
He just took it --
He put his tongue in it
and was like, "Ugh!"
-"I'm not eating that."
-I put a full spoon
of sugar in there.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
But, wow, I love you guys
for believing me.
All right.
-All right.
-Ready?
Time for round 2.
-Okay.
-The deuce.
Ready?
You're gonna have
two glasses in front of you.
One has vinegar.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
The other has water.
[ Laughter ]
-I know. I don't know.
[ Inhales sharply ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Suga, your turn.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right!
Press Jimmy if you think Jimmy
drank the vinegar.
Press Suga if you think Suga
Who drank the vinegar?
Ready?
Everybody ready?
Okay, the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
The audience thinks Suga
is the imposter.
Okay. Let's find out
who drank the vinegar.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
-I drank the vinegar.
Ugh!
That was disgusting.
That was disgusting, dude!
I'm crying. I'm crying.
[ Laughter ]
That was disgusting!
Oh, my gosh.
-Then you're gonna love
this next one.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Next one?
-It's time for the final round.
For this one,
you each have a chicken wing.
One has no spice --
mmm, tasty.
The other has been doused
in Trinidad Scorpion Hot sauce.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
-I never heard of that.
-Well, it's hotter
than a ghost pepper.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
I think you need
a license to touch it.
Okay.
-But he has to --
He has to perform tonight.
-Well...
-He has to sing.
He has to --
Jimmy, whenever you're ready.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Okay.
-Okay, Suga. Your turn.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
Okay.
Gonna count those votes up.
That's scorpion hot pepper.
Votes are in.
Let's see what we got.
They think Jimmy did.
Okay.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
-No vinegar, no hot.
Well done, audience!
Jenna, here's how this works,
okay?
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
describe it to your opponent.
Then they have to guess
if you're lying or telling
the truth.
Jenna, you pick the first box.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Three?
[ Drum roll ]
-You are choosing three.
Huh, it looks --
it looks light.
-[ Groans ]
-Yeah, too late.
Too late to act now.
-Now?
-Too late to act now.
I know it's light.
Are you going to lie or are you
going to tell the truth?
Very interesting. Jenna Ortega.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Tapping ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, I see.
You're making sounds.
You're distracting me. Yeah.
-You don't know what's
happening to you.
-What is in your box?
-Can I be honest with you,
Jimmy?
-Yes, you can always be honest
with me.
-I don't -- I'm -- I'm not sure
I even understand
what's happening here.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't understand
what's happening?
So, this thing that you are now
looking at,
you don't understand.
-I don't.
-Can you describe it?
-I fear of being a bit too
on the nose,
but it is
"Addams Family"-themed.
-Yeah. Well, we knew that you
were coming on.
-Cousin Itt.
Yeah, well, it would make sense.
-It would make sense.
We did book you.
-Cousin Itt.
He happens to be reading
a magazine of some sorts,
perhaps like "Vanity Fair"
Chewbacca edition?
[ Laughter ]
-Cousin Itt is reading
a magazine
and it could be "Vanity Fair."
-Yeah, on a nice bench.
-Bench? So, he's outside.
-Yeah, he's outside.
It seems to be a nice park,
Central Park,
if you will, in New York.
-Oh, it's New York.
So he's in Central Park?
-There may be a corgi involved.
-It's a corgi?
-Yeah.
-So, Cousin Itt owns a dog?
[ Laughter ]
Cousin Itt owns a pet?
-I guess so.
-So there's a lot of hair.
There's a lot of hair.
Is Cousin Itt wearing a hat?
-Yes, he is.
Like he always does.
He always has a hat.
-Yeah.
But if you took your time
answering that,
that would mean
that you're lying.
So I think that you are...
telling the truth!
[ Drum roll ]
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-Wow!
"Vanity Fair."
-Honestly --
-Chewbacca? It's weird.
That is odd.
-Yeah, I should have lied
because it's way too niche.
Like, the "Vanity Fair"
Chewbacca article, instantly --
-Yeah, we wouldn't do that.
Alright.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
[ Drum roll ]
-Two! Two!
-Oh, my back!
-I already did that.
-[ Groaning ]
Ooh!
-Ohh!
-Ooh! Here we go.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
It's a painting.
-Painting of what?
-Famous, famous,
famous painting.
Something you'd see in a museum.
-I feel like you have to be
more specific on this game.
-I don't think -- I don't want
to be more specific.
I want to be vague.
Think of a famous painting.
-Oh, so it's just a painting.
Don't tell me it's
the Edvard Munch, the --
-"The Scream"?
-Ooh.
-Ooh, that's interesting.
-That's a bit on the nose too.
-Well, you do have a movie
called "Scream" coming out.
So, that's pretty funny,
not niche.
[ Laughter ]
Now, now, here's what makes it
funny.
It's not -- The painting's face.
It's Colonel Sanders.
[ Laughter ]
-Colonel Sanders is very funny.
-Colonel Sanders is funny.
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
[ Laughter ]
I love this.
In fact, I want to keep it
and hang it in my bedroom
because I love it.
It's so funny. There you go.
It's "The Scream,"
Colonel Sanders scream.
-Honestly, I feel like
Colonel Sanders is pretty funny.
Just to repeat myself.
-He's not supposed to be funny.
He's selling food.
-I think it's -- I think --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I feel like you might be telling
the truuuuu...
[ Woman shouts indistinctly ]
-Did you just say something
in Spanish?
Wait, what did you just say?
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
I feel like you just helped
somehow.
-Maybe it's a lie. Maybe it's a
lie. Maybe it's a lie.
Maybe two on-the-nose
references.
I'm sorry, I'm taking forever.
It's just 'cause
I really don't know.
I don't really care.
I'm going to go with truth.
[ Laughter ]
-No! I was lying!
[ Buzzer ]
The "Mona Lisa."
-Oh, my God. You just took --
-Really a good actor.
Thank you.
-No.
-Did you say my acting skills
are fantastic?
That's so nice of you.
-Yeah, that's ex-- Yes.
-Thank you!
Thank you!
[ Laughter ]
Time to pick a number.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
One more.
[ Drum roll ]
-I'm serious.
-This is it.
This is it.
For all the marbles.
Jenna Ortega, pick a nombre.
Uno.
-Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wow, it's a bowling ball.
It's a bowling ball. Wow.
Alright, so it really is heavy.
Oh, my goodness. Alright.
-What if I broke it
or something?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Sorry.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
♪♪
-Why are you being --
Why are you being so serious?
♪♪
Roots, your music is, like,
giving me trips or something.
I'm tripping out.
I'm like, "Wah, wah."
-Uh, we have, um...
It's a bobblehead.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-It's a bobblehead.
-It's a bobblehead?
-A bobblehead of Peter Pan.
Um, he seems to be in a bit more
of a --
like a -- like a business
attire.
[ Laughter ]
He's got kind of
like the Leonard Cohen --
-Peter Pan in, like,
a business suit?
-Peter Pan in a business-esque
suit.
He's wearing a hat that's a bit
more of like
a Leonard Cohen fedora hat.
And he's --
[ Laughter ]
-Leonard Cohen. That's so funny.
-But it's also in a cowboy hat
with wheels
and marshmallows all in there.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you just naming words?
Are you just saying words?
-There are so many marshmallows
in there.
-You just said 20 words.
-There's so many marshmallows
in there.
-Peter Pan is on a marshmallow?
-No, there's -- So, cowboy hat.
-Uh-huh.
-Truck wheels.
-Yeah.
-Bunch of marshmallows in there.
In there is a bobblehead
figurine of
Peter Pan wearing
a business suit.
[ Laughter ]
-If you're lying,
it's pretty good.
You have a good imagination.
If you're telling the truth,
props to my props department.
[ Laughter ]
Props to props.
Welcome back to
"Props to Props."
-Yeah.
-Jenna, I feel like
we're besties.
And if we are, I would know
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
And I think you are...
[ Drum roll ]
[ Laughter ]
...telling ze truth!
-I lie.
-Oh, my God!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Bell dinging ]
Come on!
Here's how
the game's going to work.
We're going to take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the
curtain will be something
neither of us
have ever seen before.
It could be people.
It could be objects.
It could be anything, okay?
Once the curtain opens
and you pick up your card,
you have 45 seconds to get
the other person to guess
what's behind them.
-Okay.
-You can say anything you want.
You can use gestures.
You just can't say any of
the words on the card.
-And we have 30 seconds?
-Yeah.
-Did you say 30 seconds?
-I said 45.
-45. Okay.
-Do you want me to change it?
-Do you want to make it harder?
-I feel like, you know...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Kate, you'll be guessing first.
Let's get into position.
-Okay.
-Look at the budget on this.
-Are we supposed to --
-No, get ready for this.
Just sit and enjoy.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-I'm scared.
-Oh, yeah.
-Whoo!
-Look at this.
This is unbelievable.
This is all of our budget.
All of our budget.
Yeah, now let's open the curtain
and see what is behind you.
-Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm so excited.
It's the number-1
TV show on Netflix, a TV show.
-"White Lotus."
-No, yeah, but, see, it's a --
-"Stranger Things."
-It's a family of...
-On Netflix.
-...scary things.
-Scary things.
Oh, "Wednesday."
-Yes!
Wednesday is with
a person who is a chef
who wears flames on his shirts.
-Oh, Bobby --
-No, it's not Bobby.
-Shoot!
-The other one.
-No, yeah, with the white hair,
the whitish hair.
-Yes.
-I don't know his name!
-No, I know it. I know it.
-If you don't know someone's
name, you go, "Hey, G--."
-Hey...guy.
-Yes!
But what's his name?
-Guy Fieri.
-Yes, that's correct!
And, together, they are
putting together something.
When it's not raining,
but it's --
-It's raining. It's storming.
-In the wintertime.
-It's snowing.
-Yes. What would you make?
What would you make?
-A snowball.
-No, but a bigger one.
-A snowman!
-Yes! That's correct!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Okay. Okay.
-That is exactly right.
Wednesday Addams and Guy Fieri
building a snowman.
Oh, my God. Well done.
Well done.
That is a very good job.
Good job.
Wednesday, you're very upset.
Guy, nice to see you.
Ooh! Now it is my turn to guess.
Let's rotate.
-I love this. Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright. Here you go.
-Okay.
-Okay, and now let's see
what's behind me.
-This is the best.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay. Okay. Can I go?
Can I go?
-Yes, yes.
-Okay. He's a Marvel --
-I can't even hear you.
-Marvel --
-Oh, Marvel.
Spider-Man.
-No, Mark Ruffalo.
-Oh, Hulk, Hulk.
-Yeah.
And women do this a lot.
And they go and they do it
to their va-jay-jays.
And --
-Bedazzle them?
-No. Well, interesting.
Very interesting.
So, or, you know, it hurts.
Ow! Ow!
-Oh, a Brazilian wax.
-Yeah, or just a...
-A wax.
-Okay, great.
And our president.
-Joe Biden.
-Yeah.
-Wait. So The Hulk
is waxing Joe Biden?
-No. Yeah. No.
No, The Hulk --
-The Hulk is getting waxed.
-Yes. His back --
-Back waxed from
President Joe Biden.
-Yes.
-Alright.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow.
He doesn't look happy about it.
-Fanta--
-He doesn't look happy about it,
but President Biden does,
weirdly.
He's happy about it.
And The Hulk --
Oh, The Hulk is upset.
He's upset about it.
-I love it.
I mean,
president is very pleased.
-Do you think that he went into
this as Bruce Banner
and the pain turned him
into The Hulk?
-Oh, my God.
-I appreciate you guys.
Well done.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here we go. It's your turn.
-Okay.
-You got this, partner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Mmm, ahhh ♪
Alright, let's see
what's behind you.
-I'm scared.
-Okay.
-What is that face?
You're making a face.
-I know one of them.
Alright, it's a -- Okay.
-Okay.
-Alright, it's two men.
One man is cleaning products.
-Oh, Mr. Clean.
-Yes, thank you.
Yeah, kind of. Alright.
I can kind of say -- Eh,
"cleaning products" I can say.
Sorry. Sorry.
Mr. Clean.
-Okay, Mr. Clean.
-Alright.
And then it rhymes with that,
but he's a
British physical comedian.
-Oh, Mr. Bean.
-Yes.
And they're bouncing on
something that rhy--
-A trampoline!
-Yes! Oh, my God!
[ Dinging ]
-Whoo! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Mr. Bean.
-I know, Mr. Bean.
No, it's Mr. Bean.
-I mean, that's pretty good.
-What's he doing?
-He's being a Mr. Bean.
-Yes, he's being very Mr. Beany.
And he's doing -- And then
he winks a couple times
and then he shakes his head
and then he's twisting --
Look, he's twisting
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, he's shocked.
Mr. Bean is shocked.
Okay, this is great.
Thank you, Mr. Clean.
Thank you, Mr. Bean.
-Thank you.
-On trampolines.
-They're rebounding.
They're rebounding.
-Alright,
this is the final round, okay?
This is a big deal.
This is worth --
-We're winning.
-This is worth all the points.
-Okay.
-So if you're watching at home
and gambling,
please don't gamble on this.
You have a problem.
But this is
worth all the points.
If we win this,
we're champs for life, okay?
-Okay. Forever.
-Forever and ever.
Let's rotate the stage, please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright, here we go.
-It completely rotates.
-Yeah, wait.
Why don't we just turn
our chairs around?
I could face that way.
We spent all this money
on this stage.
We just -- But the chair
can spin around.
Got to work on the budget here.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see --
-Okay.
-Let's see what's behind me.
-Ooh! Okay.
♪♪
Okay. Okay.
Oh! Okay. Alright.
This guy -- Oh!
This guy Austin just played
in the new movie --
-Elvis Presley.
-Okay.
Is playing with a thing
that kids love to play with
on trees at birthday parties.
-A piñata.
-Yeah, but he's also,
instead of the piñata,
hitting a very
Christmasy cookie.
-A gingerbread man.
-Yes!
-Is that correct?
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoo!
-I can watch this
for 25 minutes.
This is fanta--
Elvis, take another -- Hiya!
Oh, come on, do one more, Elvis.
This is worth it.
-I did that really...
-Oh!
Guys, Kate Hudson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please welcome
Millie Bobby Brown!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi! Perfect.
That's Millie Bobby Brown!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Millie, nice.
You came right in there.
Millie and I will be
facing off against
one of her co-stars on
"Stranger Things."
Please welcome the one-and-only
Noah Schnapp!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
-Don't get scalded
by the coffee.
You okay, buddy?
You came in hot, buddy. Wow.
-I did not expect that.
-Yeah, came in hot there.
Alright, perfect.
Alright, here's how this works.
-I'm so sorry.
-No, it's too late now.
-Only Noah.
-Alright.
In front of each of us...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true.
The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then you have to come
to a unanimous decision --
is it a truth or a lie?
Millie,
you're going to go first.
Which envelope should she open?
What do you think?
1 or 2?
-Oh, we pick?
-Yeah, or the audience
could pick.
What do you think?
-2.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
2!
-Everyone said 2.
I don't know why.
-I sneak my pet bunny
into hotels.
♪♪
-That's...
-You know Millie very well.
-I think that sounds
like it could be real.
-Why would you sneak your bunny?
Why can't you just check it in?
-Millie is, like,
obsessed with animals.
-Alright. But why do you
have to sneak it in?
-Because, usually,
they let in dogs and cats,
but probably not a rabbit.
You know?
It might become an issue.
-What do you mean?
Because that feels like --
Well, you would know
it's an issue, right, if you
already -- If you tried --
-I feel like Millie, though,
wouldn't be sneaky about it.
She would just walk in.
-Yeah, because
she just loves animals.
Yeah, she would just
walk in and say,
"Hey, I have my bunny with me."
-Yeah, she wouldn't care.
-Everyone loves you.
Everyone would let you in
with anything.
You can go in with a chainsaw
and like,
"Yeah, I'm going to go to
my room with a chainsaw."
They'd go, "Millie, come on in.
We love you."
-Maybe.
-I don't think --
-I'm saying lie.
-Oh, wait. Whoa, whoa. Wait.
-But then I've got to
pay a deposit
if he does something, right?
It's like, uh,
do I really want to do that?
No.
-She's so lying.
Are you kidding me?
She's such a liar.
-Why would you stay in a hotel?
Don't you live in England?
-I do, but I was
filming in the city.
-No, this is --
I know when she's acting.
This is a lie.
-This is a
total, complete, absolute lie.
-Like, you can't even try.
-You can't even describe this.
This is such a lie.
Tell us right now --
truth or lie?
[ Drumroll ]
-It's the truth.
-No!
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Guys!
-You played us.
-Why did I come here?
-Dude!
-You played us like
a deck of cards.
-Wait.
I said truth from the beginning.
-Yeah, you did say -- Yeah.
-I knew it.
My instincts said true.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, no. It's a true story.
And it did become an issue.
Like, the guy --
-Did they find it?
-They did.
I went into the elevator
and I put him under my sweater.
And if they ask,
"I'm breast-feeding my child.
Why would you ever ask me?
That's so inappropriate.
Where's your H.R. lady?"
Anyways...
And then, he buzzes
when he gets really happy,
and he was buzzing
under my shirt.
And his ear came out
of my shirt,
and the guy looks.
And I went, "Look away."
And I got off.
And then I put on my
"do not disturb" sign
on my door for like five days.
-So you did get away with it.
-I did, I did, yeah.
-Oh, my God. Alright.
Good job. Congrats.
Good on you.
You got points for that one.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. It's my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
-Oh, my God!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Dude!
-1.
-We'll go with 1.
-Okay, be careful, 'cause I
don't want to be able
to see through -- Okay.
Oh, yeah, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, yeah. I got worried.
-LeBron James called me
from the court during a game.
-That's so cool.
-That's really cool.
I think it's almost
too cool...for you.
-For me?
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
"I think it's almost
too cool...for you."
Yeah.
-Okay. When?
-This was probably about
four years ago.
-Who were they playing?
-Oh, four years ago?
-They were playing the Nuggets.
Or, no, the Warriors.
The Warriors.
Golden State Warriors.
-What did you talk about?
-What do you mean?
They didn't have a chat.
He was just --
-He called you.
Well, he called you.
Did you answer?
-Yes, I did.
-And what did you say?
-So, what happened was,
I went --
-You're lying.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he's lying.
-I feel like I almost --
-I'm going to take this.
I'm gonna dip this in
a little bit more coffee
and let you think.
Think it over.
-Okay, what do we say?
-Ew!
-What do we say?
What do we say? What do we say?
-What is that?
-Alright, together.
-It's a lie.
[ Drumroll ]
-It is a lie, yeah.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
-He would never do that.
He would never do that.
-Never do that.
-He would never do that
during a game.
You knew it.
Noah, it is your turn.
Noah, which one?
-1!
-Okay, 1.
-Come on, bud. We got this.
Enola, let's put our
detective skills to the test.
-I guilt-tripped Shawn Mendes
into following me back
on Instagram.
-This is something he would do.
-It sounds like something --
Yeah, it sounds like --
When is this?
-A year or two ago.
-Okay, why did you
guilt-trip him?
He didn't want to follow you?
-Well, he followed everyone else
in the cast except me.
-Shawn Mendes?
-Yeah. He followed you, Sadie,
Gaten, Caleb -- everybody.
-Oh, he's bitter.
-What's his problem?
-Yeah, he's mad.
-This is real.
-And I was like, "What the heck?
Why does he
follow everyone but me?"
-Yeah, what's
Shawn Mendes' problem?
-You're lying.
-He has beef with me.
-So, then how did you
get ahold of Shawn Mendes?
-I DM'd him and I was like,
"I'm low-key offended.
Why do you follow everyone --"
-Did you say,
"I'm low-key offended"?
You said that to him?
-You can't DM someone
if they're not following you.
He's lying!
-No, no, no.
Jimmy, that's not -- Jimmy...
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, am I -- Did I just
show how old I am?
-He showed his age there.
-Shh.
-Okay. I thought you had to
follow each other to DM.
-No!
-No, you can DM anybody.
-You can DM anybody?
-Jimmy, Jimmy, stop.
You need to stop.
-I'm not even on --
I'm on BeReal now.
-Oh, he's so hip.
-I don't even care.
-What did he say?
-Yeah, what did "Men-Men" say?
-He said, "Oh, what's up, man.
Like, I love you so much."
-He does say, "What's up, man?"
He does use the word "man."
He's like, "Hey, man."
He's Canadian.
-He's a fellow Canadian.
And he was like --
-Shawn -- Well,
he's a very nice guy, Shawn.
-Oh, I'm sweating.
-When is the last time you
talked to Shawn on Instagram?
-I called him the other day.
-Oh.
-That is absolutely --
This such a lie.
-Yeah.
-That was what -- That's it.
It's over. It's over.
-It's a lie.
-You called him the other day?
Why would you call him if you
have him on -- If you're DMing?
I'm going to say it's a lie.
-It's a lie.
-It's...the truth.
-What?!
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
Wow!
Wow! Acting. Acting.
Mastermind. Noah Schnapp.
-Oh, my God!
-He did it again.
-My thanks to
Millie Bobby Brown,
Noah Schnapp.
"Bron-Bron," give me a call.